Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of the
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Doctor Matthew Lindauer. He's an
associate professor of philosophy at Brook Brooklyn Brooklyn College
and the CUNY Graduate Center and an associate professor
of psychology also at the CUNY Graduate Center. And
today we're going to talk about his book, The
Fruitfulness of Normative Concepts. So, Doctor Lindauer, welcome to
the show. It's a big pleasure to everyone.
Thanks so much. Great to be with you.
OK, so, I mean, for people who of course
haven't read the book, er what is the main
argument of your book? I mean, er what exactly
do you explore there?
Yeah, so, as someone who, um, was trained at
Yale in the PhD program at Yale, I was
doing a lot of kind of traditional political and
moral philosophy, thinking about immigration justice and our duties
to the global poor. And I was also working
in, uh, Joshua Knobe's lab, uh, and getting into
kind of empirical research, and I had this motivation
to think about how these things can hang together.
Um, AND there's famously difficulty putting these two, you
know, descriptive and normative or the is a divide.
These are kind of famously difficult questions, and I
guess I thought that there was a piece missing
in the discussion of how empirical research could inform
work in moral and political philosophy. So in particular,
so the book is called The Fruitfulness of Normative
Concepts, and the idea is that I noticed that,
um, either explicitly or implicitly. Many times moral and
political philosophers were appealing to Considerations about what happens
when a given concept like justice or maybe a
conception of justice, like justice as fairness, is implemented
in the world. What will happen when it's implemented,
you know, what happens when people internalize this concept
of justice. Can this concept generate consensus among people
of diverse backgrounds? Those are kind of practical factors,
right? Um, SO, I think of that as ways
in which these concepts can help us to solve
practical problems. They're fruitful in that way, they're supposed
to be fruitful in that way. And then, the
natural, uh, coming in point for empirical research is
that you can't know what concepts will do in
the real world without, without at least consulting good
empirical research, but also often we're going to have
to, I argue, conduct new empirical research, and philosophers
need to be involved in doing that to ascertain
facts about the fruitfulness of normative concepts. So the
basic idea is, in order to evaluate. Concepts, we
partly have to pay attention to their fruitfulness. Fruitfulness
is an empirical phenomenon, therefore, empirical research is deeply
part of moral and political philosophy. It's not just
something that's of side interest, it's actually part of
doing the evaluation of these concepts.
Yeah, you, you mentioned Doctor Joshua Nova. I've had,
I've had him on the show and we talked
a lot about experimental philosophy, but I mean, how
do you look at the relationship between, uh, theoretical
philosophy and experimental philosophy, and then also between on
the one hand, uh, theoretical and experimental philosophy, and
on the other hand, science.
Yeah, yeah, this is a great and wide ranging
question, and, uh, in some ways I try to
narrow the scope of the book to really only
focus on normative concepts, uh, and in particular, even
within the normative, I say I'm really focused on
moral and political concepts, not normative concepts from aesthetics
or epistemology, OK. But your broader question is very
interesting, um, and, and important, and I would say
that, um, I think, and this is taking a
note from Josh in a way, um, I think
if we went to someone like Aristotle or David
Hume, and we said, look, we've developed all these
neat scientific tools, tools of modern science, the scientific
method, right? And we just weren't going to use
them at all to help illuminate. Enduring questions about
the human condition and about the nature of the
mind and about the nature of reality, they would,
they would be completely flummoxed, right? They say, why
wouldn't you use these tools, right? So I think
um One way of looking at philosophy, and this
is from another old teacher of mine, George Beler,
who has a very different kind of view, is
that philosophy should be thought of as kind of
autonomous from the sciences for the most part, and
I, I, with all respect to George, um, I,
I deeply disagree, and I think that that idea
that we would limit the kinds of tools that
philosophy had at its disposable, it's sorry, at, at
its disposal to only kind of armchair reflection and
logic, um, really is out of step with the
history of philosophy, that's really just a particular period
in the 20th century, and not even the whole
20th century of Western philosophy. Um, SO I think
that it's more continuous with the history of how
philosophy has been done around the world, um, to
think that scientific, um, research methods and empirical facts
could go into our philosophical reasoning. Um, NOW, I
still think it's really important, and this is why
I wrote a whole book about it, to articulate
how scientific research can inform our understanding of philosophical
questions and issues, because it's not the case that
every scientific question is a philosophical question. It's not
the case that every result from experimental moral psychology
about how people think about right and wrong, is
relevant to what is right and wrong. So, I
have, I have a kind of view where we
have to be really careful about this. We shouldn't
just say, oh well, you know, everyone, you know,
you do armchair philosophy, I do empirical results, and,
you know, we have like a kind of unspoken
agreement. I said, I say in the book where
we just kind of like agree to tolerate each
other. I think we can do better than that.
And my book is part of trying to piece
together that project in a kind of piecemeal way,
focusing on the normative uh areas of philosophy.
Yeah, you know, I'm always talking about this anecdote,
but I can't remember exactly. I wish I remembered,
but exactly when this was, but uh, it was
either the late 2000s or the, the early 2010s
where, uh, Neil deGrasse Tyson and Richard Dawkins were
at this, uh, event, at this public event, and
in the Q&A. Uh, uh, Richard Dawkins was asked,
um, why people should trust science, and he said
something like, oh, because it works, because planes fly
and stuff like that, and both he and deGrasse
Tyson, uh, I'm not sure if Neil deGrasse Tyson
still has that, uh, opinion on philosophy, probably not,
but back then they said that, uh, philosophy is
basically obsolete, and I, and I mean. I, I,
I, I don't, I don't think that, uh, that's
a fair thing to say because I mean science
very much needs philosophy and philosophy very much needs
science and I mean I, now what. I can't
even read theoretical science. I mean, whatever kind of
science it is, either theoretical psychology, anthropology, or physics
or whatever, without thinking that the scientists are doing
philosophy without even noticing it.
I think you're completely right. I, it's not unexpected
that people popularizing science would sometimes try to give
the boldest, you know, view of its importance and
its importance over all other fields, um, but, you
know, most scientists that you talk to will have
much more sophisticated views about how theory, uh, is,
you know, um, is important to science, how there
are interesting decisions to be made about How to
balance different theoretical virtues and constructing scientific theories, there
are questions about values and, I mean, the whole,
whole history of philosophy of science is fascinating. Um,
IF you told someone like Albert Einstein, Uh, you
know, or Isaac Newton, that, you know, philosophy was
irrelevant to science, they would, again, they would be
flummoxed. So I think that this is, um, you
know, understandable, and I, I hope to also, you
know, make a, make a contribution to these kinds
of discussions where it's not just sort of like,
oh well, that's, that's arrogant or something, it's also
like, no, we can, we can talk about the
ways in which, you know, go read what philosophers
of physics have to say, you know, is what
I would tell these people, you know, read what
Evolutionary biologists and philosophers of biology say about about
theory, and I think that that's, that's um, that's
going to be, you know, more informative, but of
course, you know, Unfortunately, um, I, I think without
knowing it, some of these ways of, um, denigrating
philosophy play into a certain kind of anti-intellectualism, that's,
that's just a problem in general, and so that's
another reason to be careful about these kinds of
matters, I think.
Yeah, I, I mean, Einstein was very much influenced
by Kent, by Schopenhauer, and many of the physicists
from the late 19th century and early 20th century,
particularly the ones who worked on, uh, worked in
quantum physics, also said they were influenced by Schopenhauer,
so I mean,
I guess his important work was a priori, um.
Also the influence of of David Hume on Darwin
is something people are writing about a lot right
now. Um, YEAH, yeah, so I, I just completely
agree with you and um Yeah, but it's OK.
I mean, I think that, uh, in the spirit,
there's something kind of nice about the, the bold.
I, I like objections. My favorite chapter, right, was
the 3rd chapter where I addressed like 12 objections.
It's like, bring all the punches. I think that,
you know, Uh, you know, educated, you know, kind
of calm, thoughtful people are able to like address
these things with reasons, um, yeah,
mhm. OK, so, uh, let me ask you then,
how do you look at the relationship between moral
philosophy and moral psychology?
Another great, that's a really great question. So, part
of the difficulty of answering is that moral psychology
is, is a term in philosophy that means different
things to different people. Um, SO some people think
of moral psychology as like just studying the nature
of action or the nature of intention or something
like that, and that that's all really interesting, the
nature of autonomy. Um, I think that a broader
heading, um, which would be more inclusive of a
lot of the most influential work in moral psychology
now. IS to say that it's the study of
the moral mind. It's the study of how humans
think about topics like right and wrong. I would
also want to, it's unfortunate that the word moral
is the only thing in there, because I also
think we think about ethical topics as distinct from
moral topics, like how to live a good life,
and it's not always the case that the That
the good life is, is exhausted by moral considerations.
There are also questions about, you know, I have
recent work with my colleagues, uh, Anna Gantman and
Jordan Wiley on like aesthetic pursuits and aesthetic excellence,
right? And there's epistemic excellence, and there's friendship. There's
all kinds of things that are not purely reducible
to morality. OK, so that said, moral psychology, the
study of the psychology of values, and, and, and
the things that humans value, the things that humans
care about, right? Um, NOW we can ask questions,
what should humans care about, right, in moral philosophy.
What should they value, right? What is right and
wrong, right? And of course, there isn't a 1
to 1 mapping between our answers to questions in
the first domain, right? And our answers to questions
in the second domain. So, but nonetheless, of course,
I think that there's an important, there are important
relationships between the two areas. One reason why there's
an important relationship that I like to bring out,
uh, is, you know, I can, I can refer
to a quotation from James Madison in the Federalist
Papers, uh, he says, um, paraphrasing, if men were
angels, we would have no need for government. Um,
SO, so, so I think of it, I think
of that as more as equally appropriate to morality
and justice. If we were angels, right, if we
were these beings with no Material needs, if we
had unlimited altruism, if there was no scarcity in
our world, right? Uh, WE had unlimited attention, right?
Never, never got tired, all these things that make
us suboptimal beings. It's not clear that there would
be any need for us to be constrained by
morality. We would just always help people when they
needed help, we'd always support the right things, we
would never be driven by vanity or envy or
lust or any of these things, right? We would
just be driven by the things we should be
driven by in each case. Um So that's one
reason why there's kind of a deep relationship between
how human beings are and how we ought to
be. It's that thinking about how we ought to
be only arises as a question because of the
kind of beings that we are, the kind of
imperfect beings that we are. That's why we have
to think about how to be. It's, it's because
we live in in collectives, right? We live and
we, we benefit more from cooperation than isolation. And
so these questions of how we ought to be.
Naturally arise as solutions to those problems, right? Um.
Now, OK, so it must not be the case
though that the solutions, these theoretical solutions to these
problems are too divorced from the kind of beings
that they are. They shouldn't be solutions to problems
that angels might have. They should be solutions to
problems that the kind of beings that we are
have, and that's why I think that that despite
being distinct, in some ways, there are deep interrelationships
between, um, you know, broadly speaking, empirical moral psychology
and moral philosophy.
Right, I, I mean, I was going to ask
you, uh, what's the relevance of science to ethics,
but let me, let me perhaps uh uh broaden
the, the question because I mean, I, I always
think about because of conversations I've had on the
show, like for example with Doctor Owen Flanagan, I
mean I really love his book, The Geography of
Morals and. And, and things like that. I, I
mean, I, I tend to fall very much on
the side of moral anti-realism because I think that
we can, uh, very much explain why people in
different contexts, different socio-cultural contexts and across time. Uh,
TEND to adopt certain kinds of moral values because,
I mean, they are, uh, uh, I mean, I
think that we can very much explain that through
anthropology, evolutionary theory, uh, sociology, uh, and so on.
So, um, I, I mean, but do you think
that Uh, science can actually, uh, solve questions like
questions regarding meta ethics as to whether, for example,
there are really objective moral values or not. I
mean, what, what is the, uh, what do you
think is the relevance of science to ethics?
Yeah, yeah, it's a great question. So, so I
think that, um, It depends on how broad you
think the domain of science is. I would say
that the empirical results of studies or empirical data
about history or about anthropology alone will not resolve
questions about how we ought to live. It'll tell
us a lot about how we work, how human
societies have worked, why different values arose in different
places. And now we can ask, we can ask
questions, what should our values be, right? How should
we live? And what I want to say is
that scientific research should go into the mix of
things that we consider when we examine those kinds
of questions. So when you want to know what
kinds of values should we have, are, are there
ways in which our values are suboptimal? They're not
helping us solve the practical problems that we actually
face, right? You should be consulting and conducting empirical
studies to partly Inform your answers to those questions,
but it won't be as if we can read
the answers directly off the page, as it were,
directly off the data, um, and I, and I
think that just in general, there is always theory
and a certain amount of philosophy that goes into
interpreting scientific data, right? Um, BECAUSE, um, the data
does not uniquely determine a particular interpretation of itself.
There's always a kind of philosophy going on there,
um, so, so that, yeah.
OK, so, uh, but, but I, I mean, tell
us then what is the fruitfulness of normative concepts.
I mean, what does that mean?
Yeah, yeah, I've alluded to this idea. So the
central idea of the book, and I'm, I'm borrowing
this term from Rudolph Karnap, so people might be
familiar with Karnap's work on fruitfulness in theory construction
and I'm I'm using it slightly differently than he
did. Um, SO what I mean by fruitfulness is,
um, the extent to which moral and political concepts
like justice, solidarity, well-being, empowerment, the extent to which
they are useful to us or helpful for us
in solving practical problems that inevitably arise in collective
and cooperative living. So concepts are fruitful to the
extent that they do so. My account of fruitfulness
is multi-dimensional, um, so this includes things like. What
do these concepts help to motivate? What do they
prevent? Like, when you think about, when you care
about justice, or when you think about justice in
a certain way, what are the kinds of things
that are taken off the table for you, um,
because you're committed to justice, um, what will generate
consensus, what will guide action, um, what helps us
fight back best against problematic social phenomena like racism
and bias and misogyny and so on, right? So
those are dimensions, those are, those are factors that
Make moral and political concepts fruitful, right? And then,
of course, as I mentioned, um. Ascertaining whether philosophical
concepts are fruitful in these ways is partly an
empirical matter, so you have to do empirical research.
I've done a lot of empirical research, people might
be familiar with on the tendency of moral arguments
to actually um increase charitable giving. Um, SO we
had, uh, in a, in a paper with Peter
Singer and colleagues, we have the first paper finding
that a rational argument can actually motivate as much
charitable giving as even a very powerful emotional appeal,
like the picture of a single child, which was
kind of the, the quintessential emotional appeal in the
literature at the time. So, philosophical arguments and appeals
to rationality can be very powerful. In motivating more
altruistic behavior, um, that's the kind of thing just
as a, you know, that would fall into the
first category of motivational fruitfulness as I call it,
but there's, there's much more to the picture, but
that's the basic idea, uh, is that, um, Moral
and political concepts are fruitful to the extent that
they help us to solve practical problems that arise
in in the world.
Right, uh, tell us about the lock and key
analogy that you use in your book. I mean,
what is that about and how does it play
into the argument or into what you explore in
the book.
Yeah, so I, so, of course, there's another way
of looking at moral and political philosophy, um, that
says that questions about fruitfulness, you know, factors about
what happens when we implement these concepts, these are
completely, these might be of interest to someone else,
like a marketer or a political scientist, but they're,
they're not philosophically significant, right? So I think of
thinkers like GE Moore, Derek Parfitt, I kind of
go through some of the arguments that these people
make, Jerry Cohen. Uh, IN political philosophy and David
Esplund, um, I was thinking that, um, You know,
justice should not be tied in any way to
practical effects of thinking about justice in particular ways,
um, and, and that's true of other, you know,
ethical theories for people like Moore and, and Parfitt.
Now, What I want to say is let's go
back to this thought that moral and political concepts
arose for a reason. Um, THEY probably wouldn't have
arisen for angels, right? So, they arose because we
are imperfect beings and we, we also face these
practical problems, um, given our, not just, not just
that we're like flawed creatures, but we, we have
needs, right, and the world does not perfectly satisfy
our needs, so we're always gonna have to solve
those kinds of problems together, right? So you could
think of these concepts, kind of like keys that
help us to unlock those problems. So, um, and
I'm borrowing this idea of concepts as solutions to
problems, by the way, from, um, although I think
she would have very strong disagreements with how I
think of this Christine Cos guard's idea that normative
concepts are solutions to practical problems. So imagine that
taking that idea further, just let's think of this
lock and key analogy as, right, normative concepts are
like keys that help to unlock practical problems, right?
Now. I think that with this other tradition in,
in moral and political philosophy, um, we're in a
kind of fundamental disagreement that goes back quite a
long time about the purpose of normative theory. You
can see it in Plato and Aristotle. Uh, Aristotle
has a really nice, uh, phrase in book two
of the Nicomachean Ethics where he says, um, We
study ethics in order to become good, and then
the next, the next phrase that he adds, which
I wouldn't go so far as to say is,
otherwise there are some, it's translated usually as something
like, otherwise there would be no point. Um. So
who is, uh, it seems pretty likely that what
he's contrasting his view with in ethics is Plato's
view that there's kind of an a temporal, universal,
you know, uh, idea, you know, there are forms
of right and wrong, right? And I, and, and,
uh, Jerry Cohen, you know, will refer to Plato
and Platonic views, you know, there's kind of moral
Platonism or moral realism as you referred to it
earlier, this kind of view that, um, The facts
about what's right and wrong just have nothing to
do with solving practical problems. For Aristotle, the problem
is to become good. How do we become good,
right? How do we live well? That's what moral
theory for him is supposed to help us to
do. So now, because I'm, because there is this
kind of fundamental disagreement between roughly people who are
more in Plato's camp and more in Aristotle's camp,
which is not to suggest I'm like an Aristotelian
and I'm not a virtue ethicist or something like
that, just, I agree with Aristotle to that extent,
um. I don't think you can usually uh You
can't usually approach um fundamental disagreements about how to
do philosophy head on. So what I instead try
to do is I try to build up the
best version of this other way of thinking about
Moral and political philosophy, what would it mean to
really develop a theory of how moral and political
philosophy should incorporate empirical research, and what do we
get out of it? What are the nice things
that you get out of it in the end?
And then we kind of see if the, the
proof is kind of in the pudding. Is this
something that, you know, you like, if you're someone
who's kind of neutral between these two perspectives. OK,
so going back to the lock and key. Again,
this is not meant to be a knockdown argument,
but just as a suggestive idea that I bring
in throughout the book, kind of like a red
thread running throughout each chapter. Imagine if you had
people who were locksmiths developing keys that helped to
unlock. Locks, right? And they were doing a better
job, you know, the first lock was not particularly
good or not very strong, so we do some
refinements here and there, and we think about different
locks and the kinds of different kinds of keys
that we need to develop. But what if those
locksmiths got really obsessed with the practice of just
making keys for the sake of making keys, without
attention to the fact that keys are supposed to
open locks, right? So they keep developing these more
and more intricate, you know, beautiful keys, um. You
know, careful attention to the teeth of the key
and kind of ornate design of the handle, right?
Well, that might be a really nice thing on
its own, but it seems like things have gone
off the rails in some respect, right? Because the
purpose of a key is to open a lock.
So that's, so the thought is that moral and
political philosophy should remain grounded in the idea that
what we're trying to do is open, is open
locks. We're trying to develop keys for opening locks
and um. That aim, um, is something that, um,
we can lose sight of if we do philosophy
in a way that's not tethered in any respect
to the solution of practical problems.
Mhm. Uh, SO in the book you talk about
5 different dimensions of fruitfulness of, uh, normative concepts
and the norms, theories and principles that fall under
them, and you, uh, talk about motivation, fruitfulness, prevention,
fruitfulness, resilience, fruitfulness, consensus, fruitfulness, and. Guidance, fruitfulness. So,
uh, could you tell us about them and I
mean, what do each of them, uh, refer to
exactly? Yeah,
sure, great. So this is This is trying to
explore the contours of this idea that moral and
political uh concepts help us to solve practical problems,
because that could mean you can solve practical problems
in many different ways, right? So, um, right, you've
just, you've just mentioned the dimensions of fruitfulness that,
and there might be others, I've tried to be
as exhaustive as possible, but I would love to
find out that there are other dimensions of fruitfulness,
um, so motivational fruitfulness is, as you suggested, um,
So when we think about concepts and then we
get more specific, we focus on what roles, but
also like contemporary cognitive scientists like Jake Quilty Dunn
would, would, would point to as like conceptions of
concepts. It's like specifications of the material that we
refer to that's organized by a concept, so. Rawls'
conception of justice is justice as fairness, right, and
includes the difference principle, so these are more specific
ideas. So even when two people, so Rawls and
Nozick are both talking about justice or Rawls and
Jerry Cohen, they think that different conceptions of justice
are more choice worthy than the others, right? And
sometimes the reasons he gives have to do with
things like motivational fruitfulness or consensus fruitfulness, so. So,
now, when we evaluate things like principles of justice,
norms, right, theories, uh, arguments also as what I
call conception delivery delivery devices, so they help, they
help to motivate a conception, um, we can ask
questions along these five dimensions. So the first is
motivational fruitfulness. That's how will people be motivated to
act, right? When they internalize this concept. So 11
way into this, this dimension is to think about
the self-effacing this objection to consequentialism. Um, SO this
objection says that, um. If people internalize the consequentialist
principle, which is, you know, acts are roughly just,
um, to, to put it briefly, um, an act
is right or wrong depending on whether or not
it maximizes overall good consequences, and then of course
utilitarians are consequentialists who max who measure the consequences
in terms of utility and we have other versions,
right? OK, so the, the objection goes. If people
internalize the consequentialist principle, they will not do a
good job at meeting that principle's own end, at,
at bringing about good consequences for various reasons, you
know, people are self-interested, they're bad at calculating, you
know, long term consequences and so on, right? Now.
I'm not taking a stand on whether that's a
good objection to consequentialism. What I'm pointing out is
that that objection presupposes that it matters what happens
when people internalize a theory. You could just turn
around and say, it doesn't, right, uh, what happens
when people internalize the theory and whether the theory
is true or false, are just, they're just at
right angles, right? But people making that object that
objection are committed. To something like motivational fruitfulness mattering
in the evaluation of a theory. Um, NOW another
really interesting literature that I've done a lot of
work in, uh, where motivate where what I call
motivational fruitfulness comes up is the literature on our
duties to the global poor, the duties of affluent
people, uh, in, you know, Western societies primarily to
the global poor. So there's this debate between On
the one hand, Peter Singer and on the other
hand, theorists like Alison Jagger and Thomas Pogey about
how to understand our duties to the global poor.
Singer argues, you remember this shallow pond argument, right?
That, um, we can extract very strong duties. Merely
from the idea that we ought to help people
in need, right, in serious need, when it's at
little cost to ourselves, that it would be morally
monstrous not to help a child who's drowning in
front of us, right? Help them out of the
shallow pond, if all it meant was that we
might miss a job interview, you know, might lose
out on getting a higher paying job or ruin
our clothes, as, you know, different versions of this
case, so. So if that's true, if we think
that a person has to take on this kind
of cost to save a life, right, then we
need to take on at least that much cost
to save lives all the time, and we can
do that quite easily through giving to effective charities.
That's the argument in a nutshell. Other theorists like
Jagger and Poggy, um, focus on the idea that,
well, it's not as if the global poor were
just kind of in the pond when Westerners came
along. It's we're kind of more like people who,
who either push the child into the pond or
whose ancestors pushed the child into the pond, right?
And so we have a different kind of duty,
not a duty merely to help, but we've in
some sense violated some sort of duty not to
harm, a negative duty, as opposed to a positive
duty, as it's put. OK. Now. There are difficulties
with that view because just the ordinary citizen with
all their own problems of, of Western societies, you
know, which are also facing kind of authoritarian backlash,
it's not clear that, you know, there's such a
strong causal tie between things that I do or
other people do maybe who are less less advantaged,
um, and global systems like global, you know, global
poverty or. The history of colonialism or something like
that, right?
Yeah, yeah, in that, in that specific case it's
not even clear that the vast majority of the
population were part of, uh, the colonizer countries even
played any role in that or uh gained anything,
anything from it, right, it was mostly the elites,
so.
Precisely. So there might be variation of responsibility depending
on how much your, how much your current advantages
depend on a history of wrongs and exploitation and
things like that. Um, MY colleague Christian Barry and
my, um, yeah, sadly departed, um, friend and colleague
Gerhard Overlin did a lot of work on enabling
harm as a distinct kind of causal relation to
global poverty that we might be in, and we
did some empirical work together a paper years ago
exploring that, but. So, back to motivational fruitfulness, in
that literature on global poverty, people didn't just say,
well, it doesn't matter whether these appeals, these ways
of arguing for our duties to the global poor
work in practice. Actually, in that literature, people like
Judith Lichtenberg, Holly Lawford Smith, Poggy himself, they made
claims about what I'm calling motivational fruitfulness. What will
be more motivating? Uh, SO Judith Lichtenberg puts it
really nicely. She says that there might be a
paradox of positive and negative duties, that on the
one hand, The singer style argument might be more
widely accepted, um, um, because it's, you know, it
doesn't implicate us in guilt for, you know, large
scale global, global atrocities and problems, um. And we
can all see, you know, I mean, these ideas
of, you know, children in, in ponds and drowning
in wells go back to Confucius and other, other
thinkers who mentioned similar examples, so, it's something that
motivates people. Um, ON the other hand, it might
be following empirical work on what's called the act
omission distinction or doing allowing distinction, that people are
more motivated, if they accept that they have done
something wrong, they'll be right, you know, if you,
if you tell me, look, you knocked over this
kid and now he's in the pond. As opposed
to shouting at a bystander across the way, look,
this child's drowning. I, I really have the duty
to do something about it, right? So, um, so
that's, those are empirical predictions about what will motivate
people and what will be widely accepted. And I
wanted to say these people were committed to something
like motivational fruitfulness mattering, um, to questions about what
our duties actually are. Um, AND so that that's,
that's another area, and I've done a bunch of
work in it that we might talk about later.
Um, SURE, so just to go through the other,
if you want me to go through the other
dimensions more quickly,
yeah, yeah, yes, yes, please,
yeah. Yeah, so the prevention fruitfulness is just the
flip side. It's not how people will act, but
it's how they'll be prevented from acting when they
internalize moral and political concepts, and there's really interesting
work by people like Keith Payne and Cordelia Fine
and Jeannette Kennett showing that. Contrary to the views
of people like Jonathan Haidt, it's not the case
that moral reasoning is just always kind of a
post hoc post hoc rationalization of like what we
thought anyway or what what our feelings told us.
Um, ACTUALLY thinking in moral terms can help us
to proactively head off bias and prejudice in our
own, in our own hearts. We're actually able to
use moral concepts, um. It's like a commitment to
egalitarianism to prevent ourselves from, from doing the wrong
thing by our own lights, and that's, that's what
I would think of as prevention fruitfulness. Um, A
third category is what I call consensus fruitfulness, which
is along the lines of Rawls' late project in
political liberalism. It's the thought that. Look, we live
in multi multicultural, multiracial democracies, we have, you know,
hope, you know, we hopefully are committed to that,
many, most of us are, I hope, uh, and
we wanna think about how we can converge on
ideas of justice, and, you know, how our society
should look in like a less abstract sense, um,
despite the fact that we disagree about like huge
questions like, does God exist, and what is God
like, and how many gods are there, and, you
know, How, what food should I eat, you know,
for ethical reasons, we disagree about all kinds of
first order religious, spiritual, ethical questions. Nonetheless, we have
to live together. Rawls offers justice as fairness as
a model for something that people with all these
diverse, um, other commitments could come together on as
an idea of justice in a liberal democracy in
our time and then, uh, colleagues like my some
of my work with Justin Brunner explores whether Rawls'
predictions about whether his conception of justice really is
the kind of thing that people tend to agree
on most is, is right and. We, we find
that, you know, while we applaud Rawls' commitment to
empirical research, uh, in terms of consensus fruitfulness, some
of his predictions don't bear out. Um, AND then
the last two dimensions are. Guidance fruitfulness, this is
sort of like action guidance, like does the theory
provide helpful guidance to agents looking for what to
do to solve practical problems. And then the, the
other one is called resilience fruitfulness, which uh, uh,
is the idea of it's certainly related to the
other dimensions, but the idea of like what conceptions
help us to fight back best against problematic social
phenomena, and I'm, I'm, I'm drawing on work by
Sally Hasslinger on the idea that our conceptions of
gender and race should not just be like. Reflecting
true facts about gender and race, but should actually
help us to address, she says, um, misogyny and
racism and things like transphobia, um, and so that
would be the kind of thing, um, that we,
I, that I'm interested in in this this other
dimension, resilience, fruitfulness. Does this conception of justice or
or of these other partly normative, partly descriptive concepts
like gender and race actually help us to fight
back against things that are already problematic in our
societies.
So, uh, I mean we're going to get into
the objections and challenges to your theory of normative
fruitfulness that you also tackle in the book, but
just before that, is the theory of normative fruitfulness
that you explore or develop in your book domain
specific to the normative or could it be extended
to non-normative concepts?
Yeah, so, so I'd, I'd love for the theory
to be domain general, um, but I do the
kind of classic philosopher thing, and I actually think
that this is more accurate of saying, um, I
really only think that um the argument applies to
this domain of normative concepts and again particularly to
moral and political concepts that So if you think
about, you know, motivating the right kinds of action,
preventing the wrong kinds of action, generating consensus, it's
not really clear that a scientific concept like electron
or planet is really responsible for doing those kinds
of things. And so, part of what this is,
is an intervention in this literature, uh, what's called
conceptual engineering, which has arisen in the last 10
or 15 years, and the idea there is that
we should be thinking about. You know, Hess Lager
is a big figure in this, uh, as well
as others, but we should be thinking about how
we should revise our concepts to better serve certain
kinds of practical purposes in the world, um, and
I think that that literature has been too broad.
It's in general, it's tended to focus on concepts,
you know, on mass and not really distinguish between
different types of concepts, and when you think about
those kinds of dimensions of fruitfulness, it really seems
like, you know, gender and race. Serve very different
kinds of roles and are um responsible for um
addressing practical problems that concepts like planet or electron
or sex hormone or intelligence, you know, concepts in
both the natural sciences and social sciences just don't
have very much to do with. Um, I like
in the book to go through this kind of
joke example of when the International Astronomical Union revised
the definition of planet, um, there were, you know,
I think it's 2002, right, it wound up, um,
Uh, changing the status of Pluto famously from a
canonical planet to a dwarf planet, right? Like, my
kids have a book here about when Pluto gets
the call, it's really funny, right? But there were
these protests, but they weren't real. I have photos
from them, and even the son of the guy
of Clyde Tombaugh who discovered Pluto is there having
fun. Nobody's actually saying that ordinary, you know, citizens
should get to decide what The concept of planet
is, um, the only people who thought that actually
were members of the Illinois State Senate who actually
tried to, um, they, they, they passed some kind
of silly, silly, uh, attempted legislation, and, and the
reason was that, uh, that uh, Pluto was the
only planet discovered by an American. And uh if
you're laughing, uh, yeah, if you're laughing as I
am, so that's the wrong kind of reason to
oppose the revision to a concept like planet, right?
And these protests are, are fake protests, they're fun
protests, they're not real protests like no kings or
something, um, because it's really not our place as
non-experts about planets to decide the concept of planet,
but notice that. For moral and political concepts, there
is a sense in which ordinary people have to
be able to understand and use them for them
to serve their proper purposes in solving problems. Take
the concept of blame, right? Like if, uh, you
know, imagine I blame you for something that you
just can't, you just have no understanding of what
I'm blaming you for, right? There's a kind of
performance error in doing that because the point of
the concept of blame. People like Miranda Ficker would
say is to help to, you know, align our
moral understandings to repair relationships, to, you know, give
rise to certain kinds of, uh, reparative emotions and
statements and things like that, right? That doesn't happen
if the concept of blame is just kind of
completely unintelligible to ordinary people. So, these are some
of the reasons why I think, and I have,
you know, the second chapter of the book really
treats this in much more, um, you know, sustained
detail, but these are some reasons to think that,
um, The the theory is domain specific to the
normative. The kinds of practical problems and practical desiderata
that normative concepts are, um, responsible for, you know,
um, addressing, um, are just very, very different from
the kinds of, um, desiderata that other kinds of
concepts discussed in the conceptual engineering literature, um, relate
to.
Mhm. So let's, uh, talk about the challenges and
objections. I mean, the, the first one you tackle
in your book. Uh, HAS to do with, uh,
I mean, it, it, it would accuse your theory
of being committed to an implausible form of moral
relativism. So explain that objection and then, uh, what
your reply would be.
Yeah, yeah, thanks. Um, SO, Some people might be
troubled by the thought that when we focus on.
The fruitfulness of normative concepts, we're thinking about whether
these concepts help us to solve practical problems and
so as problems change, as conditions change, as people
and cultures change, different concepts might be more or
less fruitful over time and across space, right, in
different contexts, right? So that might, does that imply
some kind of, oh, you know, scary form of
relativism where certain things are right for you and
certain things are wrong for me, um. And I,
I have a different kind of orientation than people
who are so worried about moderate forms of relativism,
um, you know, uh, So, so I'll say, I
think we might, we might get to this a
little bit later, um, but basically I see this
as a feature rather than a bug of the
theory. Um, IN particular, as you mentioned, uh, you,
you kind of alluded to this earlier, um, when
you, when you mentioned Owen Flanagan's work, um. If
you think that normative concepts arise to solve practical
problems in the times when they do, and, you
know, even theorists who are quite committed to caring
about justice, think that like Rawls talks about like,
Justice, you know, liberal theories of justice arise in
order to solve problems having to do with religious
toleration, roughly, right? And he's still focused on that,
and then in some ways that work though, winds
up being not really that helpful for thinking about
practical problems that we're addressing now, right? So it's
a feature of the view that it gets to
say, look, maybe some of these liberal ideas, uh,
you know, religious toleration certainly very important, but strong
ideas of private property in particular. ARE going to
jar against problems like rad, you know, radical runaway
economic inequality. We're gonna have, you know, potentially our
first, you know, trillionaire on Earth, right? Billionaires have
more and more power, ordinary people have less and
less power, um, they're potentially devastating effects on labor,
um, of, you know, new technologies, which, you know,
that's an open question, um. We're certainly told that
this is going to be so important, um, but,
but, you know, related to this, um, Climate change
is another one, right? Uh, CLIMATE change really is
a hard problem to address. Matthew Feinberg has a
lot of really great empirical work on how our
current moral thinking is really almost the opposite of
the kind of thing you would want, if you
wanted to design agents to address a problem like
climate change, right? It's like long term, it's hard
to see the consequences, uh, it's hard to spell
it out in terms of individual actions, it's structural,
all these kinds of things. So, So I think
that the theory helps to explain why we, we
see conceptual change over time. It's also kind of
culturally tolerant. It, it helps us to try to
interpret practices, not in terms of, oh, there are
those strange people over there doing different things, but
to think about why this particular normative framework arose
in a different kind of place. What were the
kinds of practical problems that people were facing? What,
what are the kind of facts on the ground
that lead to this practice, that might help us
to actually understand. Other people more rather than condemn,
to borrow, you know, Spinoza's dictum to what we
seek to understand rather than um condemn. Now the
further, the last thing about that, that might, uh,
allay people who are really worried about, you know,
relativism, is that there's still the meta moral question.
OK, so we have this, different things are potentially
fruitful in different environments and times and places, but
still, at least across space, you know, just across,
across physical space, we still have the question, how
do we interact with people globally, right? How do
two people from two different cultures or two societies
interact with one another, and that's not a question
that can be addressed just by thinking about fruitfulness
within one context. That's a meta moral question which
is in some sense more similar to Rawls' last
project in the Law of peoples. Um, IT'S designing,
you know, solutions to kind of global problems, and
again, his own solutions are not ones that I
think, you know, now look that helpful, but he's
still very attuned to this idea. That we should
be using normative theory to try to solve practical
problems. So that would lead to a kind of
more pushing toward objectivity, at least across physical space,
this meta moral problem, how do we have these
global interactions? Of course, across time that things might
change, um, that would be, it might be relative
across time. Right,
uh, how about the objection that your theory would
make morality overly concessive to people's moral failings?
Yeah, so this is an objection that comes out
of work from people like Jerry Cohen and David
Estlund, that there's a kind of chilling effect of,
you know, if you focus on, so if you
say something like, um, Well, it would be a
great thing if people gave a certain amount of
their income to charity, but you know, people are
just too selfish, like studies show, the classic studies
show thing, studies show that people are just too
selfish to be expected to do that. So therefore,
they're not required morally to do that. That seems
like, wait a second, you can't, that's, that's a
circular argument, uh, you know, there's something, there's something
at least deeply wrong with that way of reasoning,
and I would say, well, sure, um, it's possible
to try to use empirical results to downgrade our
moral expectations, but we can oppose those kinds of
arguments in just the way that I just did,
we can point to flaws with moving from descriptive
facts about people's moral limitations to facts about what
they're morally required to do, um, and you know,
there's a wide literature on the, um, The odd
implies can principle and nearby principles that like, it's
just a completely independent thing of like whether empirical
research goes into our understanding of moral um theory,
but notice that my focus is not on downgrading
moral expectations. If anything, I think my research, especially
on global poverty. Um, SUGGEST that rather than, um,
conceding ground to our moral failings, we should be
thinking about how to optimize people's moral behavior. What
are the kinds of ways of appealing to people,
giving people a little bit more credit than that,
um, what kinds of ways of appealing to people
with reasons and arguments and principles can actually generate
the most cooperative and good behavior. So, in slogan
form, I say the, the focus is on, uh,
optimization, not concession.
And does your theory fail to take morality seriously
enough, and uh what does it mean to take
morality seriously enough?
Yeah, so I'm, so this is a phrase from
uh the book Taking Morality Seriously by David Enoch,
and I, you know, I, for all the people
I mentioned, I mean this, their work has been
very, very interesting and and insightful, and I, even
though I'm responding to it, I just want to
say that. So, so this, uh, this, so Enoch's
idea. Is that, um, Moral realism, the idea that
there's a kind of objective mind independent reality, is
the only kind of meta-ethical theory that takes morality
seriously, in the sense that it really responds, it
really, um, reflects the strength of conviction with which
people, people arrive at moral, when they arrive at
moral disagreements, the kind of strength of their conviction,
right? So, You know, you and I disagree about
whether strawberry ice cream or chocolate ice cream is
better. It's like, well, Ricardo, you have what you
want, I'll have, I'll have what I want, that's
fine. But if we disagree about a moral topic,
you know, David Young says, well, we're probably more
likely to like dig in our heels and assert
that only one of us can be right. And
that kind of level of That shows that it's
not really just a matter of taste for Enoch,
um, it's, it's a matter of something that we
at least are committed to thinking is objective, right?
I'm right, you're wrong kind of stuff, right? So
I have a few things to say about this,
um. One is that It's not necessarily the case
that the only way to take morality seriously is
to dig in your heels in moral disagreements. Another
thought is that being a moral person might involve
trying to see others' perspectives in a kind of
deep way and trying to think about where other
people are coming from and maybe trying to locate
reasons why we have different values, right? And why
those different values might actually be justified to each
of us given the kind of different backgrounds we
have, what Rawls calls the burdens of judgment. Um,
ALL kinds of facts that make different kinds of
evidence look more and less appealing to, to each
of us. So, I don't think that taking morality
seriously necessarily means always digging in your heels, that's
one thing, um. A further thing though, is that
it's not necessarily the case that um. Just because
you think that fruitfulness or pragmatic factors, for instance,
are relevant to the assessment of moral and political
concepts like justice, it's not necessarily the case that
then when you're opposing an injustice or involved in
a moral disagreement, you will be thinking about those
kinds of meta-ethical facts at the time. Like I
give an analogy to like a a a soccer
player or a baseball player, let's let's do, let's
do soccer, football, as, as people around the world
call it, right? So there are rules in this
game. Right? And of course, a soccer a given
soccer player, right, um, uh, you know, like Lionel
Messi or someone like that, um, they could be
thinking, they could like get lost in thought and
think, should the rules of soccer be different, right?
Like how penalty time works or something. Should that
be different? Would that be more responsive to the
point of this game? Would that make this a
better version of the game? And we know that
the rules of games do change over time, so
people do sometimes do this. But it's not as
if when Messi is up there about to score
a, you know, about to shoot a penalty kick,
it's not like he's captured by this thought about
whether or not the game of soccer is as
it should be, whether or not it's as fruitful,
you know, a game as it could be. And
that's just true of social practices in general. Um,
WE can think about things like, you know, should
marriage, should we think about marriage differently? Should we
think about friendship differently? Should we think about democracy
differently? Without being demotivated from caring about sticking up
for those things, or, you know, motivating ways, you
know, defending those things in various ways in the
moment, um. So it's not the case if take
like someone like John Dewey, who is like a
much more thoroughgoing pragmatist than me. He's more like
the domain general kind of guy, right? Um, YOU
know, someone's quite committed to racial democracy, and, you
know, to to multiracial democracy and doing a lot
of really important practical work. So, I think that,
um, That idea that we can glean meta-ethics from
facts about how people approach moral disagreements kind of
elides this distinction between different levels of theoretical consideration.
There's the, the internal point of view on the
practice, and then of course we can take the
borrowing HLA Hart's term. We could take the external
point of view, and we could think, is this
practice the right practice? Should it be reformed in
various ways, so it's not incompatible with taking it
seriously. It's actually, for me it's part of taking
it seriously.
Yeah, uh, OK, so let me just say because
I, I could just not leave that unaddressed that,
uh, when it comes to chocolate ice cream and
strawberry ice cream, chocolate is clearly superior, so, and
it's not a matter of taste, I mean, I'm
willing to die on this hill, it's a matter
of, uh, it's a matter of epistemology,
so, well, we, we happen to agree, but, um.
You and my 4 year old son will be
locked in a very long standing fundamental disagreement because
he's a partisan of strawberry.
OK. So, uh, another objection then, uh, does your
theory suggest the wrong kinds of reasons to act
morally?
Yeah, this is a related consideration, so, um. Again,
like, you know, if someone is, uh, deciding whether
to attend like a no kings protest or whether
to donate some of their money to an effective
charity to help. Children who are suffering from the
effects of severe poverty, uh, is it the right
kind of reason for them to act? Should they
be thinking, well, Is my action, the kind of
action that's informed by the most fruitful normative concepts
or something like that, right? Does fruitfulness enter into
that? So sometimes people make this kind of wrong
kind of reason argument against various moral theories, not
uniquely my own, but the idea is that the
reasons that the agent acts on. ARE different from
the kinds of the kind of fruitfulness-based reasons for
which, you know, I'm, I'm, I'm thinking we should
be thinking about whether this moral framework is a
good one or whether this concept is a good
one, right? And I, I, I just would go
back to some of this, I addressed this question
kind of similarly to the kind of Lionel Messi
kind of example, right? So, Messi's reasons for scoring
goals are very different from the reasons that he
would bring to bear in thinking about whether soccer
should be different or what team he should play
for, you know, how, how teams should be funded.
There are all kinds of meta questions about the
structure of a practice that are different questions than
the question, what reason should motivate within a practice,
right? And that's, that distinction actually goes back to,
uh, Rawls's famous paper 22 concepts of rules. Um,
THAT are reasons within a practice can be distinct
from reasons why we have the practice in the
first place. So prooffulness applies at the level of
why we have the concepts in the first place,
and then those concepts and conceptions of them will
have implications for what kinds of age, what kinds
of reasons agents have when acting under those concepts,
but they won't necessarily be. Just completely, you know,
isomorphic, um, there's a 1 to 1 correlation between
the reasons for retaining the practice and the reasons
why agents act within that practice. Mhm.
Uh, AND another objection, uh, has to do with
whether your theory makes us overly reluctant to engage
in transformative experiences. I mean, in this particular case,
what is, or what would be a transformative experience?
And then tell us also about your reply to
that objection.
Yeah, this was an interesting point that an anonymous
reviewer for OUP brought up, and I thought it
was really worth, uh, including in the book. So
thanks to that anonymous person. So, Transformative experiences, this
is an idea coming from the work of a
philosopher LA Paul. So So Paul is, is working,
thinking about epistemology, thinking about the epistemology of rationality.
She's thinking about certain kinds of choices in life
that are transformative in two ways. One is epistemically
transformative. They're such that we can't know what they
will be like before engaging in them, uh. So
once you have that experience, your life may be
so different that you, you just can't know beforehand
whether or not you would want to have that
experience, um, or to, to get to the other
side of that experience. Um, THEY'RE normatively transformative in
the sense that they can reshape our values. Uh,
SO it might be that once you have this
experience, your values change deeply, and the core example
of all this, she talks about, you know, uh,
examples like, you know, whether to become a vampire,
but the real kind of example that she's focused
on is parenting, and the thought is like, Before
you become a parent, you just like can't know
what it'll be like to be a parent, um,
and you also don't know like whether or not
your values will change a lot in virtue of
being a parent. I really, I, I hope mine
have not changed that much. I hope that I've
just learned more about my values, but this does
keep me up at night sometimes, as, as a,
as a proud, uh, papa. So, So, OK, so,
um, what she says is that with transformative experiences,
it's, it's kind of irrational to engage in them,
uh, except for the fact that you should, uh,
it could be rational to want to have the
experience, but you can't know that it's rational to
engage in it ahead of time. Like you can't
know whether it's rational to become a parent in
the sense that it will be, you know, it's
the kind of thing that will make you happy
afterwards, or, you know, that it will align with
your values afterwards. It's only The thing that you
have to focus on the rationality of is to
make, making the choice of whether to have the
transformative experience. So now, this person brought up that
maybe my view, uh, in focusing on the fruitfulness
of our concepts, um, would actually be opposed to
our having transformative experiences because we, we assess the
fruitfulness of those concepts in terms of our current
values. And things that we currently know, and it's
sort of like transformative experiences might lead us to
have different values, like there might be different kinds
of practical aims that we have, different kinds of
fruitfulness considerations, right? So a couple of things about
this. I wound up, you know, reading a lot
of this literature, and what I think this is
super, super interesting and important contribution to philosophy, I
think that the extent to which experiences like parenting
are that, that these are truly transformative in the
two ways that she mentions are epistemically and normatively.
I think that, I think it's overstated. Christer Bickvist
in his, uh, in, in, in their, um. Book
review of, of, uh, Transformative Experiences book brings up
this nice point, and I, I really think it's
true, just to my experience that, um, Yes, uh,
becoming a parent is a very, very, very different
kind of way of being, but on the other
hand, like, if you've helped raise younger siblings, um,
if you've like done a lot of like volunteering
with like tutoring and teaching youths and like caring
for younger people, it's not as if it's completely,
it's not as if the experience of parenting is
like completely epistemically. Inaccessible to you. It's different, but
not so different that, you know, I mean, all
experiences in some sense, give us, you know, you
try a new type of sandwich, that shouldn't be
a transformative experience, so it has to be radically
different. I don't think that parenting is necessary, this
quintessential example necessarily fits, and It's not also obvious
that our values change necessarily so much, and, you
know, the same kinds of considerations that go into
assessing whether your values pre or post-parent are the
right ones to have, just to like, I don't
know, sometimes I'm like, wow, I'm focusing too much
on my kids and not enough on global poverty
or something like that, and I can like hold
myself to account about that. Much in the same
way as I would have held myself to account
as like a 20 year old single person, I
would be like, wow, like, you know, you're spending
a lot of money on like, this new pair
of shoes, like, What's up with that? There are,
there are similar kinds of normative reasoning that you
could give. So I think that that's one way
of kind of Dampening the critique. Um, ANOTHER thing
to point out, this is maybe less fun, so
I put it at the end, but, uh, it's
just that like the fact of normative that transformative
experiences exist insofar as it's a problem for the
fruitfulness theory, um, it's a problem for any of
you that says that we should revise our concepts
on the, on, you know, that, that, that sometimes
we should think about how to revise our concepts.
So any conceptual engineering kind of view faces this
challenge. Um, SO it's not like it's a unique
problem for my view, and it, it's sort of
strange to think that there could never be circumstances
under which we try to change our concepts. Um,
THE last thing is just that the transformative experiences
view is really focused on individuals, and I'm thinking
about systems of thought and the kinds of concepts
that people use together to solve practical problems. I
think that we do a lot less of that
kind of like radical conceptual transformation. As collectives, moral
changes more gradual at the collective level and more
of a piece with what came before, um, so
that's, that's another thing, there might be a kind
of lack of disanalogy between the level of analysis
for transformative experiences and fruitfulness.
Yeah, so, uh, earlier we've already talked a little
bit about the relevance of empirical research to moral
and political philosophy, but another objection you address in
your book, uh, asks whether, uh, you give us
an overly narrow view of that. I mean, what
is your reply to it?
Yeah, so this was meant to be, yeah, this
is a good question. So, it might seem that
I'm saying that fruitfulness kinds of considerations are the
only place where empirical research, you know, comes into
play for philosophy or moral and political philosophy, and
that's just, that's just not what I mean to
say. I'm, I'm focusing on this kind of what
I think is like a novel argument for why
empirical research is part of the philosophical enterprise in
moral and political philosophy. Um, BUT it's not as
if other kinds of approaches are thereby taken off
the table. Um, AND I think we just have
to think very carefully about when and where empirical
research is relevant. So in particular, like we mentioned
Josh Knobe's kind of view, and he was kind
of in this article, experimental philosophy is cognitive science,
um, he's articulating the idea that a lot of
work in experimental philosophy, um, is best understood as
not really focusing on intuitions but focusing on. Understanding
the psychological processes that underlie philosophical judgments, what makes
a given theory more appealing to someone else, someone
or a principle or a view appealing to some
people and not others? What are the psychological processes
that help to explain that? That's what he thinks
of a lot of work in experimental philosophy is
doing, and I, I think that that's very, very,
uh, plausible and interesting, um, and looking at these
kinds of psychological processes using. Scientific methods, it's just
something that I'm completely in favor of. It might
even also bear on fruitfulness considerations, right? So if
you find out that psychological processes, um, are active
in underpinning a certain philosophical theory. Where those processes
tend to lead to a lot of harm in
the world, then that might be actually a reason
to, um, uh, to actually try to avoid endorsing
that theory. It might be a reason against that
theory because it tends to involve psychological processes that
are kind of problematic, either morally or epistemically, um,
so it's not as if these different kinds of
projects are always at right angles, but I, I
wanna be ecumenical, let 1000 flowers bloom, um, kind
of person, um. But it's just to say that
I think that it's also really important to articulate
this way in which, um, Empirical research kind of
can deeply inform our answers to certain kinds of
questions in moral and political theory.
OK, so let's also talk about the implications that
your theory of conceptual fruit fruitfulness might have here
or normative fruitfulness, sorry, it might have here. So,
uh, we've already ended up talking a little bit
about some of them earlier, but perhaps you might
want to add a few points. So earlier when
we talked about the five dimensions of fruitfulness, uh,
we explored motivation, fruitfulness, but, uh, I mean, apart
from what you've already said, are there any other
implications for the nature of moral motivation and how
we approach it or not?
Yeah, so, so I do think, um, some things
that I didn't say, although that might have come
up in people's minds, um, when I was going
through some of that stuff. So, a lot of
the literature on the nature of moral motivation at
the time when I started doing this work in
graduate school. Really seem to be focused on this
idea that if you want to motivate people to
do good, you have to hit them over the
head with emotional appeals like picture of one child
in poverty, this famous, what are called the Roia
studies in the, in the, in the, in the
industry, studies by Deborah Small and colleagues where the
most motivating thing. Is a picture of a single
child, Roia, who's living in poverty, right? Um, AND
then actually appealing to rationality, not only is ineffective
in those studies but is decreases motivation compared to,
so if you pair the emotional appeal, Rokia's suffering
this picture of her with information about other children
who are suffering, you actually get less in terms
of donations than if you just talk about her.
So that seems to, that seems to suggest that
not only is rationality kind of motivationally impotent, but
it's like, it's like harmful. You should avoid anything
in terms of you know, making any kind of
appeals to people's rationality, if you want them to
be pro-social in this way. And other people picked
this up, and there was, you know, at the
time, there's a lot of work coming out of
people like Jonathan Haidt, suggesting that really rationality is
not going to play a big role in moral
judgment or moral motivation. OK, so, As a philosopher
and as a, a hopeful philosophy grad student getting
into psychology and empirical research, I thought, hold on
a second, it's not the case that the only
kinds of appeals of rationality are, you know, statistical
information about other children who are in poverty. That's,
that's one kind of, you know, data you could
provide, but As someone who, you know, my values
had been heavily affected by like reading work by
people like Peter Singer and John Rawls and Karl
Marx and all kinds of other philosophers, I, I
thought, well, there's another kind of appeal to rationality,
philosophical argument, and maybe it has a different motivational
profile, at least in some circumstances, than, um, than,
you know, presenting statistical, you know, data about statistical
victims, as it's called, unfortunate term, because these are
real people, um. So, when we ran the study,
the, the striking thing is that it's not as
if all arguments motivate, but well designed arguments that
really address people's reasons, uh, in terms of, you
know, how to think about a practical problem can
actually be as motivating as, as these kind of
very powerful Roia style single child appeals, and that's
what we found in this, in this, uh, this
first paper in. Published in judgment and decision making.
Um, SO that's a case study in motivational fruitfulness,
and then that literature really took off and other
people, I had this, you know, kind of, there's
some debates about this, but the real thing that's
coming out of a lot of work and there's
recently, you know, this argument contest study that's kind
of, uh, That that's been done by uh Kirsten
Brody and Eric Schwitz Gable and others found also
that, you know, many arguments can motivate people to
give more and, and looked at what are the
factors about these arguments, um, arguments, some arguments can
actually motivate, even, even though, um, there's a, there's
a paper by Chris McVeigh, uh, and colleagues, you
know, suggesting that narratives are more, you know, more
motivationally. Uh, YOU know, efficacious than arguments. Well, I
never said that arguments are the most motivating thing
always, but strikingly they find that some arguments can
be as motivating as the narratives in their paper.
So this is, this is the idea, it's that,
um, we should be thinking more about ways in
which arguments can motivate prosocial behavior, and some of
the reasons I didn't mention yet are really worth
thinking about. So, one is that if you. If
I show you a picture of a child suffering,
that might motivate you once, but if I show
you it tomorrow, you might say, I can't, I
can't just keep seeing these images, right? And there,
there are also concerns about, you know, what's sometimes
referred to, you know, colloquial poverty porn and things
like this, right? Like, we're kind of like exploiting
the images of people suffering in order to help
them, and that's maybe that's problematic, there's a thought
about that at least. Um, IF I change your
mind. If I get you to see the problem
differently and to do careful reasoning, right, about whether
or not you are consistent in your values, and
that changes something about you with regard to some,
you know, lifestyle choice or, or how you address
global problems, whether you go to protests or whatever
it is, um, that may be more enduring and
I have a, a kind of project in the
works with some colleagues, um, looking at whether I
can empirically support that claim, but I do think
at least. Anecdotally, and knowing people who have been
moved to change their attitudes and behaviors by philosophy
that it can be much more lasting than just
appealing to their emotions in a kind of one,
in a kind of one-off, uh, one-off shot. So,
these are some reasons to think about, uh, the
other thing is just that I think that um,
In in the politics of my country, like if
you think about the Democratic Party, very often Democrats
are like focusing on like the one big critique
of like the last campaign was like we focus
so much on not being Trump that we didn't
really stand for very much in particular. I think
that politicians, you know, even though Trump isn't really
making arguments, there's this thought of he's willing to
talk to anyone, like he went on the Joe
Rogan show and I'm, I'm not gonna like bear
on like whether. So and so should have gone
on Joe Rogan. Bernie Sanders had a different view
of this, right? Um. People like to think that
there are arguments behind what they believe, and they
like to think that the people who are trying
to convince them of things take seriously their agency.
There's some prior research showing that if you give
people bad arguments for good conclusions, they rebel against
it. They, they think that that's all you've got.
So I think that I want my research to
be part of a, of a trend of actually
trying to use philosophy and careful argumentation, even in
politics. It's not the only thing that we should
use again. But when we fail to engage people
as reasoning beings, I think that we, we lose
out on convincing people and showing that we have
integrity and all, and all kinds of goods. Yeah,
uh, so when it comes to the duties of
the global affluent to the global poor, is there
anything you'd like to add to what you've already
said earlier or?
Yeah, I mean this, this work is kind of,
you know, in an emerging literature, so I'd encourage
people to, you know, check out some of this
stuff, but I, I think that, you know, one
thing that's striking is that many of the arguments
that people thought would not be motivating have been
replicated across studies showing that they are quite motivating,
these arguments that actually Not so much that we
are doing harm to people in the global South,
like, like fit like the way you like push
a child in the pond, but more, more kind
of, um, diffusely that we participate in systems that
cause a lot of harm, and that that generates
certain kinds of duties. That's not the kind of
thing that people feel so guilty about that they
are not motivated to act, and So we find
that empirically in some of our work that people
are actually receptive to these kinds of arguments, um,
that it's not merely and that's not merely explainable
in terms of politics or religiosity or something like
that, um, but you know, if you get involved
in any kind of, you know, political spaces, you'll
find lots of people who have that kind of
view, and it's kind of their motivating view. So
I hope that, you know, we can kind of
give a rational and scientific anchor to certain things
that if we just pay attention to what, you
know, people who are motivated to act, um, what
they're motivated by, that would be a good thing.
Um, SO I, you know, just one like thing
on, on that is like a lot of research
that focuses on like moral exemplars and why people
are moral focus on like extraordinary acts of altruism,
like the person who jumps to save someone. Who
falls on the subway, or the person who donates,
you know, a kidney to a stranger, to a
stranger, or a person who donates like almost all
of their income to charity and, you know, works
as it works in this like, you know, very
undesirable, higher earning job and donates all their money,
you know, hardcore effective altruist kind of earn to
give type person. So, I'm not saying that those
are, those are, those can be wonderful things depending
on how we cash out the details, um. Um,
BUT what about the woman in the polka dot
dress who like stands up to ice, you know,
in that famous photo, like after work. Uh, WHAT
about, you know, all of the people who do
all kinds of socially important work. We should be
thinking about what kinds of values and, and, and
reasons and, and. Moral frameworks motivate those people too,
it shouldn't just be about a very small segment
of the most individualized, atomized moral agency. We should
really be doing, and I think that that's what
a lot of, a lot of my findings support
is the idea that people can be motivated by
concerns of, of justice, and they can be motivated
by these concerns for rational reasons.
Uh, HOW about the nature of justice in diverse
multicultural societies? I mean, what kinds of implications would
your theory of normative fruitfulness have?
Yeah, thanks. So, um, Well, so Rawls thought that
his conception of justice, justice as fairness, would be
kind of like the most chosen kind of conception
of justice among people who divert, you know, people
who have, you know, different religious views and who
are from very different backgrounds. And you know, again,
I, I think that there's a lot of value
in caring about what people can converge on, you
know, thinking about justice again as something that arises
for human beings because we need to solve these
practical problems together. But it turns out that when
we, when you look at the literature, and there's
a lot of recent work on this too, some
of which I've done with colleagues and a lot
of other great stuff too, um, it turns out
that Rawls' predictions probably were not quite right. It's
not the case that people tend to choose the
difference principle, in particular as the principle that regulates
social and economic equal inequalities. This is the, for
people who are not familiar, it's the principle that,
um. Social and economic inequalities can only be justified
if they're of maximum possible benefit to the worst
off. So, you know, doctors making more than gardeners
is fine because it lifts, you know, you get
more doctors, it creates more supply of doctors, and
so people are better off, you know, um, hedge
fund managers, maybe that's cut out by the, the
difference but so we have to tax them a
bit because it's not raising the worst off position,
maybe it's lowering the. Worst position in many cases.
OK, so value to that, but actually it turns
out that something like um and Interestingly, Rawls in
his last book, Justice as Fairness or Restatement seems
to anticipate this. Um, THERE'S this version of, um,
of utilitarianism called, uh, restrict, uh, restricted utilitarianism, which
says that, um, there should be a floor below
which no one falls, um, but once we achieve
that floor, we can maximize utility, taking into account
diminishing marginal utilities. It's not like we have runaway
inequality. Because more and more at the top does
not correspond to generating more utility, right? Every additional
dollar in Jeff Bezos' pocket goes a lot less
far than additional dollars for, you know, the homeless
person, you know, in, in Brooklyn, let's say. Um,
SO. That principle seems to garner more support across
a wide range of studies. There's a replication in
Japan recently. Um, ALSO, Rawls didn't really consider the
question, so he talks about what would people choose
from the original position, right? And using the original
position as this idea, you know, we don't know
what religion we're a member of, what race we
are, whether we're a man or woman or non-binary,
whatever else, right? Um. And then we, then we
would all converge on justice as fairness and the
difference principle. He doesn't ask the question, well, would
we all converge on the original position as a
way of choosing principles at the meta level, right?
He never asks the question of convergence, and that's
something that, um, in a paper in Phil studies
with uh Justin Brunner, we explored, and it turns
out that people tend to like something more like
a Smithian impartial spectator. As a method for choosing
principles of justice more than the Rawlsian original position,
um, and you know, some of this work really,
I am in many ways, as, you know, I'm
a hardcore Rolls and in some ways, there's a
lot that I've gotten out of this person's thought,
and I think I've taken it in some directions
that, you know, I wish I'd had the chance
to talk to him, uh, about this, um, but,
uh, it, it really revised my views to see
that, you know, replicated studies are showing that many
of Ross's predictions about what people would choose under
different conditions just seem not to. Come out and
people are being really careful to try to make
the experimental conditions approximate the kinds of conditions of
choice. It's not just as if a Rawls would
be able to get off the hook very easily
and be like, well, this is a You know,
these are, you know, this is just a hypothetical
thought experiment. The real world is much more messy,
you can't control for these factors. People have really
tried to control for the kinds of factors that
someone would point to in trying to make that
kind of defense work, and it doesn't look good.
So, um, this is a way in which actually
the empirical research has really shaped things that I
personally think are, you know, are right in moral
and political space.
Right. So one final question then, do you think
that your theory of normative fruitfulness could be brought
together with other more traditional approaches in moral and
political philosophy?
Yeah, thanks for this question. So I think it's
really important to, to think about this. Where does
fruitfulness. Come in. So I don't think that um
we should be taking like bad arguments or bad
the theories that we know are bad on theoretical
grounds and then seeing what they produce in the
world, kind of like a noble lie style, fruitfulness-based
analysis, right? And you know, oh, it turns out
that this generates good results and that's, that's not
what I'm saying, um. Where I think fruitfulness tends
to come in, where our focus is when we're
locked in a kind of theoretical gridlock about which
approaches are the best ones on purely theoretical grounds,
then we should examine these kinds of questions about
fruitfulness. Like take something that's already well supported on
theoretical grounds. Then these kind of fruitfulness considerations, these
dimensions are additional theoretical virtues that you can bring
to bear on the theory. So we never look
to the fruitfulness of, and so that means that
there's a lot of traditional philosophical work to be
done in constructing the theories, um, and you know,
maybe empirical work goes into that too, like, you
know, looking at which intuitions support the theory. There's
a lot of, a lot of additional, there's a
lot of remaining work to be done. Um, JUST
in constructing theories before we engage in fruitfulness-based analysis,
and then there are questions about how the reflective
equilibrium works when we move between fruitfulness and theory
revision or theory construction. Um, SO I hope that,
uh, the view is, is also, you know, going,
not going to trouble people who want to do
traditional moral and political philosophy, which I do actually
quite a lot of myself, um, the thought is
to try to Develop a theory that gives us
a compelling account of how science can be relevant
to ethics without overstepping the kind of bounds which,
you know, also pointing out ways in which philosophy
is partly independent. It's not just completely swamped by
scientific research. These things have to be brought together,
you know, bring the lab and the armchair together
in a way that's going to generate the most
defensible theories overall.
Great, so the book is again the fruitfulness of
normative concepts, so we'll be leaving a link to
it in the description of the interview. And Doctor
Lindauer, just before we go, would you like to
tell people where they can find you and your
work on the internet?
Oh, sure. And yeah, thanks so much for having
me. Um, SO, my website is Matthew Lindauer.com. Um,
MY book is available on the Oxford University Press
website and I'm also on Blue Sky, uh, primarily.
So yeah, uh, thanks so much.
No, thank you so much for doing this. It's
been a great pleasure to talk with you.
I, I enjoyed it very much. Thank you. Great
to meet you. Take care.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Eddin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel Pan
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Jr. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Ia Webb, Jim Frank,
Lucas Stinnik, Tom Vanneden, Bernard Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro,
Al Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.